olympic games on the part of the
festival and about to take place
jim kelly welcome back indoors to the
natatorium on the campus of LSU with a
champion John neighbor alongside we're
getting set for the
the men's 200-meter butterfly in lane 1
18 years old from Long Beach California
Matt Mitchell
in lane 217 from st. Charles Park
Illinois David face in Lane three Jeff
Olsen trying for a double tonight 18
years old from Austin Texas
Lane poor Jim a screwball 17 years old
from Florida in Lane five which roll
in lane six seventeen years old out of
Portland Oregon Bank Brent Laing d'Alene
7 Chris Berman 18 from Roanoke Virginia
and the lane eight Todd Robinson 18 from
Atari Louisiana okay John David Waki in
the men's 200 floor butterfly it could
be just anybody's race
six from the north gave me 17 years old
he's got a lot of strength in his upper
body too he used to use the East Coast
champion in this event in the selection
process next to him in lane three this
is Jeff Olsen we saw him win the 803
tonight 203 last night I picked him was
my favorite and over here in Lane six
with the green or the black suit green
cap this is Brent Laing from the north
spot he was a medalist to the backstroke
more links the cool butterfly it starts
to hurt Boyer
the first
nice car looks to be a very strong Under
the screen will be the far left here
just coming into view Mitchell
in lane four Jim sciutto
again it's four lengths of the pool and
as John points out this is perhaps the
most painful event it starts to hurt
very soon let's get back to
one American
and complete forelegs of butterfly
legally in other words here there's our
leader watch his way he strokes this is
Jim Oscar vault from the South team nice
blowing loping stroke but it's rotted
all the body is also undulating in other
words he's diving for drawing the
shoulders down on the entry while his
feet are kicking behind his upper body
so he can breathe and he's got a bowl
in the field he swims for the Fort
Lauderdale swim team could be a senior
and he swam before
knavery six five
full body we find
just the swallowing way
got to deal with the turbulence
our leader who's now got to relinquish
that later
I was also six five 18 years old
average roll
in lane six it's brother
but it's still rich rolled in Lane 5
there are 30 meters to the finish in
lane 5
the big move it comes Todd Robinson out
of Atari Louisiana
Lane three
too close to call its Olsen who gets up
for the gold
and tested gutsy performance from way
back in the back he was swallowing wings
couldn't even tell his time until he put
on his glasses of
markable double eight
on the programs all of that within an
hour of itself fantastic performance
that's not going to start right now this
is lane one in front of us but you're
going to see lane three three lanes up
boom out they go nice smooth entry in
the water they try to pierce the water
through a single hole and then here
comes the finish look here on the bottom
of the screen that's Jeff Olsen our our
winner look at the way he can put his
head down from this point on stroking
Wayne and he chooses to kick
taking the half stroke which of course
put in the head of the silver medalist
and boy up for real police performance
by chip holes a double for Jeff Olsen
tonight he just added a 200 butterfly
getting the silver its rich roll and the
bronze belongs to David picks